mr tom cruise there okay oh heck yeah
the special handshake tom cruise you
knocked it out
nashville tennessee that's it i spent a
lot of time there and time in tennessee
yeah
i love that accent thank you thank you i
appreciate that i love it as well and i
gotta say i loved this film
and i'm not just blowing smoke here
this is good it was so worth the wait
but sir how does it feel tonight a
special event like this in london and
it's getting the royal treatment how
does that feel it's a royal occasion
it's very special
so i'm here with the actors and
we're making the film we're talking
about moments like
this to have a premiere and i wanted
them to have this kind of experience and
then to have a royal premiere in england
it's very special it's very very special
and i imagine it's very special to have
the support of the cambridges as well i
hear william is a top gun fanatic and
you've already is this true that you've
already given him an advanced screening
of the film so this will be a second
time singing yes early on i know he's he
loves
you know he loves uh he's an aviator so
i know he'd have a lot of fun
you've got their support today have the
two of you ever flown together not yet
[Laughter]
get ready
i'm sure you know we're all like pilots
or pilots so we all want to we all want
to go flying
says it you've proven it with your
performance look maverick the ultimate
aviator you sir are the ultimate actor
where did this passion of yours first
begin for what you do you know when i
was a little kid i want to make movies i
remember being four years old literally
and the moment that i wanted to make
films i wanted to fly i wanted to travel
the world i wanted to
just wanted to travel the world and meet
people and
i was i was always curious like what's
that person like you know i want to sit
down and talk to them i want to i want
to live in their world
and i would dream of that and i was
always if you look at my films there
it is that it's that sense of
adventure that sense of
travel
and something that
i'm constantly my whole life i think
it's
it's been a
a pursuit of adventure an interest in
people and philosophy and
film and art and
constantly pushing myself that's why i
wasn't going gonna make just make this
movie it was 36 years i wasn't just
gonna
how many places i went how lucky i am
and people asking for this
i did not want
to disappoint anyone tommy you did not
disappoint very much you don't want to
make a mistake because as maverick would
say it's not what i am it is who i am
correct
spacex how are you preparing for that
yeah that's that's very technical we're
we're working on that hard figure that
one more technical than this yeah it's
you know there's there's just
there's a lot of elements that that have
to go in and it's uh it's a wonderful
story and
so we're working hard on that one
we're working hard on mission with
mchugh he and i are like we're still
like
we're still shooting that i got to
finish seven and eight we're going i
mean it's just so much fun i know
i know i'm trying i'm trying i'm trying
to deliver for you okay let me get back
on the side all right thank you so
[Music]
much you